depuis 1985 la journée du 5 décembre est
consacré au bénévolat à une initiative
de l'ONU pour mettre en avant le rôle
joué par les associations dans la
société et pas uniquement à l'autre bout
du monde pour des ONG également au
quotidien les bénévoles sont
indispensables aux associations en
France bonsoir Sylvie cardinal vous êtes
délégué départementale à la vie
associative des ivelines et puis bonsoir
à Grégoire Aska vous êtes bénévole dans
une association de l'université
Versailles 5qu en Eveline l'association
Agora Agora consiste en quoi Agora donc
vous voulez que je récapitule un peu
l'association alors l'objet en fait
c'est de stimuler la vie du campus et au
passage de stimuler l'esprit critique
des étudiants donc ça passe par
plusieurs sphères à la fois festif à la
fois sportif mais surtout culturel aussi
donc ça passe notamment par un journal
étudiant satirique ça part passe par des
conférences ça passe par des projections
et vous êtes bénévle depuis quand depuis
4 ans et c'était pour vous une évidence
de s'engager comme ça de prendre du
temps pour une association c'est venu
progressivement comme souvent finalement
chez les associatifs à l'université ça
vient peut-être parfois au départ par un
projet particulier pour moi c'était le
projet du journal et puis ensuite on se
rend compte de l'enrichissement que ça
peut apporter et on se on retourne vers
d'autres projets on s'occupe de plus en
plus de choses et maintenant du coup je
suis vice-président en ayant commencé
tout en bas de l'échelle disons il y a
une hiérarchie aussi dans les bénévoles
alors il y a une hiérarchie partout il
faut faire ces preuves un chiffre tout
de même pour débuter là cette séquence
12 millions c'est le chiffre de cette
édition c'est 12 millions de bénévoles
en France la France et même championne
européenne de la discipline c'est une
plutôt bonne nouvelle comment vous
l'expliquez oui tout à fait c'est une
très bonne nouvelle effectivement ça
veut dire que les les personnes ont
envie de s'engager euh dans des causes
queles qu'elles soient d'ailleurs ça
peut être des causes effectivement
humanitaires
social auprès de des enfants des
personnes âgées mais également des
causes
euh de type récréatif sportif euh ou
pour la défense d'opinion
euh et les Français passent du temps
dans C association parce que c'est 3,5
millions de bénévoles réguliers qui
accordent plus de 2 heures par semaine à
une association tout à fait c'est tout à
fait réjouissant pour notre société la
société civile est très importante pour
maintenir le lien social entre les
individus entre les groupes en ce qui
concerne les ivelin nous sommes
particulièrement gâté c'est un un
département très dynamique sur le plan
associatifz autour de 150000 bénévoles
et pour 15000 associations actives
actuellement donc effectivement on entre
à peu près au 15e rang national pour la
création de
d'association en France et c'est un
chiffre plutôt stable o est-ce qu'il y a
des années parce qu'on entend souvent
les associatifs nous dire on manque de
bénévol dans nos associations oui
effectivement on relève une certaine
stabilité depuis une dizaine d'années
mais au niveau national concernant à la
fois les créations d'associations
également le nombre de bénévoles donc il
y a un petit tassement qu'il est
difficile d'expliquer mais un tassement
effectivement de l'adhésion des
bénévoles à des ce type de d'activités
et peut-être au sein même de l'année il
y a une variation également je pense au
périodes de fête de fin d'année on y
approche est-ce qu'il y a plus de
bénévoles en fin d'année oui le cœur
s'ouvre en fin d'année comme c'est bien
connu effectivement euh par rapport au
reste du cœur la problématique
d'hébergement social effectivement plus
de personnes s'engagent vous parlez de
ces associations ce sont celles qui
concentrent le plus de bénévoles parce
que là par exemple il y a un associatif
qui est sur ce sur ce plateau bénévole
mais au sein d'une association
universitaire plutôt plutôt festif de
réflexion sur sur la faculté vous parlez
des restau du cœur des par exemple pas
forcément puisque effectivement ils ont
une activité plutôt saisonnière fort
heureusement les associations de type
sportif récréatif de jeunesse
d'éducation et cetera concentre le plus
de
bénévoles au niveau de notre département
combien de bénévoles dans votre
association à l'université Agora une
centaine environ une centaine sachant
qu'ussi on travaille beaucoup avec
d'autres associations et donc par
exemple on a organisé les journées de
l'économie sociale et solidaire il y a
peu de temps on a réussi à faire venir
le ministre donc Benoît amont et euh
donc tout le monde a mis la main à la
patte et on a réussi à voir beaucoup de
personnes environ 200 personnes
notamment pour la dernière la dernière
intervention celle de Benoît
amont c'est un mouvement de masse
relatif mais c'était agréable de voir
tant de gens investis mais il est
difficile de mobiliser d'éventuels
bénévoles de les faire adhérer chaque
année parce qu'en plus il y a des
périodes d'interruption à l'université
qui sont assez long les étudiants
passent d'universit c'est vrai que nous
on est pour le coup calqué sur le
calendrier annuel universitaire euh ça
passe vraiment par septembre la rentrée
ça passe par les amphis ça passe par les
tables mais c'est une action perpétuelle
tout au cours de l'année certains
arrivent par disons par certains projets
certains projets qui peuvent les attirer
certaines projections par exemple
certaines soirées et cetera c'est des
gens qui s'investiront peut-être l'année
d'après d'une autre manière plus
amplement donc finalement il y a pas on
n pas vraiment d'échéanciers c'est c'est
c'est progressif et constant on dit que
les étudiants parfois sont un peu
repliés sur eux-mêmes sur leurs
préoccupation du quotidien est difficile
de les faire adhérer à des associations
je suis relativement d'accord avec ça
c'est un travail difficile et pour le
coup on est sur le terrain en permanence
et justement notre logique c'est essayer
de sortir des carcans sortir des
filières c'est pour ça qu'on est une
association ouverte plridisciplinaire on
vise à à à disons à découvrir des choses
qui ne sont pas forcément liées à la
filière de base à ouvrir l'esprit des
étudiants et donc c'est c'est toute pour
nous c'est toute la logique associative
c'est de découvrir des choses qu'on
découvrirait pas forcément c'est la le
complément à la la la vie scolaire dans
quel type d'association pourriez-vous
vous engager nous sommes allés poser la
question aujourd'hui dans les rues du
département des ivelines un soutien
scolaire par exemple ah ou là ça semble
accessible pour moi ça serait
spécifiquement dans le domaine de
l'enfance l'aide à l'enfance voilà mais
j'aimerais trouver du temps pour en
faire bah disons par exemple faire genre
l'heure du
compte raconter des histoires s'occuper
deux jouer avec eux soutien scolaire
support support à l'éducation la
pédagogie
l'enseignement et cetera on s'intéresse
par exemple aux gens qui ont des besoins
on leur donne des vêtements par exemple
de façon très ciblée je sera intéressé
effectivement pour aider les enfants
et par contre il faudrait que je trouve
le temps comme beaucoup de gens on donne
de l'argent à des associations entre
parenthèses caritatives le cancer là
c'est le Téléton samedi bon et cetera et
cetera ENF et pour le Téléton on
l'imagine il y aura beaucoup beaucoup de
bénévoles qui seront mobilisés hein dans
le département des divlines mais aussi à
travers toute la France je me retourne
vers vous vous êtes donc délégué
départemental à la vie associative du
département des ivelines ça consiste en
quoi plus précisément ça consiste en au
niveau de des service de l'État soutenir
le mouvement associatif dans son
ensemble ça passe par le soutien à la
création lorsqu'une association dépose
ses statuts a besoin de de renseignement
de type juridique de réglementation ça
ça passe par effectivement l'accueil de
ces association lorsqu'elle souhait
modifier un nombre de de choses dans
leur vie également bon ça passe par ce
qu'on appelle le GREF pour les
dissolutions d'association mais c'est
aussi bien plus que ça c'est animer le
mouvement départemental le mouvement
associatif au niveau départemental pour
la mise en re nombre de politiques
publiques qui peuvent être en faveur de
la jeunesse en faveur des personnes en
difficulté et cetera donc pas seul avec
les services de l'État mais avec
l'ensemble du mouvement associatif qui
coopère la mise en œuvre de ces ces
politiques sans lesquelles effectivement
il serait très difficile pour l'État
collectivité de mettre en œuvre un
certain nombre d'action et si par
exemple quelqu'un décide de s'engager en
tant que bénévole mais il ne sait pas
trop vers quoi se tourner vous pouvez
l'aider le renseigner aussi oui bien sûr
on peut tout à fait les orienter vers un
certain nombre de de structures voilà ça
arrive quelque fois des gens qui ne
savent pas qui ont envie de de donner du
temps on l' entendu dans le micro pas
trop mais justement c'était l'objectif
d'hier de cette rencontre à versaill
donc de de 17h à 21h ce speed dating
cétait une première de rencontrre entre
les associations à la recherche de
bénévoles certains profil de de bénévole
et les la population qui souvent ne sait
pas où s'adresser là c'est une
opportunité effectivement intéressante
pour pour les personnes de venir
discuter rencontrer les associations et
pourquoi pas conclure un contrat de
bénévola et ce speed meeting dont vous
parlez on envoie quelques images on va
tout de suite y partir c'était du côté
de Versailles ça s'est déroulé hier et
l'objectif bien évidemment de trouver
des bénévoles les explications avec
Antonie Resche alerte association
recherche activement bénévoles une
inititive originale un speedting était
organisé à versaill pendant une dizaine
de minutes chaque futur bénévole a fait
le tour des tables à la rencontre des
associations j'avais une grande tente
qui disait toujours qu'il fallait se
rendre utile alors en ce moment je suis
disponible donc je travaille que le
weekend et du coup je me suis dit que je
pouvais éviter de gâcher mon temps
chaque association possède sa propre
équipe de salariés parfois le
préoccupation comme la séropositivité
peuvent réfrainer les ardeurs des
bénévoles le bénévola dans une
association comme la nôtre on va dire
que c'est pas très vendeur c'est
compliqué effectivement donc de
s'intégrer parce qu'on parle de
sexualité et queil y a beaucoup de gens
qui ne souhaitent pas parler de
sexualité mais effectivement on a des
gens qui arrive à passer ce tabou et à
venir donc nous voir cela dit on
aimerait bien que ce soit beaucoup plus
après avoir fait le tour des tables la
chénésienne a suler les associations où
elle pourrai apprendre des autres c'est
le loisir avec des jeunes qui ont juste
un léger retard et la deuxième on peut
apprendre le macaton donc il me semble
que c'est le langage des signes avec des
pictogrammes pour les personnes qui sont
non verbales qui sont pas capabl de de
parler Mina carbour fera très
certainement le bonheur d'une
association dans les prochaines semaines
comme les 160000 bénévoles du
département soit 10 % de la population
élinoise syie cardinal quel bilan vous
faites de cette opération écoutez c'est
une première nous sommes relativement
satisfaits en plus de 200 personnes ont
participé à cette soirée effectivement
nous allons faire un débriefing mais
déjà nous savons qu' certain nombre de
bénévoles ont pu rencontrer
l'association de leur de leur choix et
que des des des adhésions sont sont en
cours une quarantaine de bénévoles ont
pu donc trouver l'association qui leur
convient là sur l'université de versaill
50 ans vous n'étiez pas présent he sur
ce sur ce forum mais il y en a qui sont
organisés régulièrement comment vous
faites pour faire venir ces bénévol
comme je vous disais ça passe autant par
l'affichage par aller à la rencontre
nous même des étudiants et ça passe
aussi par effectivement quelques
journées organisées il y avait le forum
des associations au début de l'année
donc c'est l'occasion de rencontrer les
étudiants dans un cadre vraiment défini
pour ça et
puis ce qui est intéressant de ce ce
qu'il faut vraiment accentuer quand on
parle aux étudiants c'est c'est le côté
non visible de ce que rapporte
l'investissement euh l'investissement
permettre pas pas forcément passer à
TVfil mais ça peut aider ça peut aider
en tout cas à ne serait-ce qu'
communiquer avec avec les autres ça peut
faciliter d'autres choses par exemple ne
serait-ce que pour les entretiens
d'embauche on peut être nettement plus à
l'aise ensuite d'aller vers les autres
et de discuter en en public on peut être
plus à l'aise sur beaucoup de choses et
puis par exemple je pense au journal
c'est l'occasion pour des étudiants qui
voudrait se dessiner pe au journalisme
qui ont l'imagination de d'être créatif
de de même d'améliorer leur sens de la
rédaction enfin c'est voilà ça passe par
ce genre de choses et puis ne serait-ce
que l'administratif aussi parce que
gérer un projet c'est aussi aussi gérer
beaucoup de paperasses euh beaucoup de
coup de téléphone beaucoup de
négociations de de lieux et cetera et ça
ça on s'en sert toujours après en fait
donc on en retire toujours énormément de
choses vous vous êtes engagé pourquoi
vous moitiv ce qui m'a motivé c'est de
de à la fois remuer un petit peu un
petit peu tout tout ce qui peut se
passer à l'université c'est dans une
visée professionnelle aussi moi dire ça
fait une expérience aussi euh ça rejoint
c'est donc c'est c'est venu
progressivement finalement le projet du
journal oui effectivement pour moi c'est
devenu un projet euh l'écriture et le
journalisme culturel mais quand je
j'organise une conférence c'est pas à
viser professionnel c'est aussi pour et
surtout là peut-être idéologiquement
chez moi il y a ce côté de vouloir enfin
à vouloir ouvrir l'esprit des étudiants
leur faire découvrir des choses qui
découvriraient pas forcément d'instinct
et leur permettront peut-être par la
suite comme je disais tout à l'heure le
complément à à la vie scolaire
finalement il existe aussi un Passeport
Bénévole on va peut-être prendre
quelques instants pour en parler ce
Passeport Bénévole permet de de
reconnaître un petit peu l'activité qui
est menée par un bénévole et ensuite ça
peut lui servir pour un pour un CV par
exemple pour la validation des acquis de
l'expérience aussi oui tout à fait la
fameuse VAE effectivement c'est toujours
bien dans un dans un cricum vité de
faire état de ce ce passage de bénévolat
hein les Américains savent très bien
utiliser ce type de de signal
effectivement de plus en plus nous
pensons que les les jeunes et les moins
jeunes mais surtout les jeunes doivent
pouvoir bénéficier de cette ce passeport
et c'est assez valorisé parce que c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui encore peut-être
quand on remp son CV on mais et aussi je
fais partie de tel à T association mais
c'est vraiment mis à la fin du C culture
nous sommes pas encore là mais
effectivement les choses les choses se
développent et de plus en plus je pense
que les employeurs seront attentifs à à
ce type de d'engagement et à le
développer donc par la suite vous
imaginez le mettre en avant sur votre CV
justement de dire j'ai déjà fait tout ça
ça permet de se créer un réseau aussi
peutêtre ça peut permettre de se créer
un réseau et il me semble effectivement
qu'on a ce retour pour avoirà chercher
des petits boulots et cetera le weekend
l'associatif c'est toujours intéressant
ça montre aussi qu'on est capable de
s'intégrer dans une équipe ça montre
qu'on peut être autonome mais ça montre
qu'on il y a une sorte de capacité à
l'autoformation permanente par là voilà
qu'on retrouve parce que comme je disais
il y a vraiment comme on le voyait dans
les reportag il y a multiplicité de de
sphères différentes dans l'associatif
dans le bénévola euh des choses qui vont
dans le solidaire et cetera comme les
associations ICAR par exemple à
l'université le développement durable
auquel touche aussi ICAR mais faculté
d'agir il y a vraiment multiplicité de
sphères et pour le coup quand j'évoqué
les journées de l'ESS ce qui est
intéressant là-dedans également c'est
que c'est une une approche de l'économie
qui se développe seulement à
l'université et euh c'était l'occasion
disons d'avoir un premier contact et de
de voir vers où ça va donc effectivement
c'est valorisable et valorisant je pense
prochain rendez-vous pour votre
association Agora à l'université alors
le prochain rendez-vous c'est une
projection du film Les nouveaux chiens
de garde donc on reste dans les médias
euh donc une projection du film suivi
d'un débat avec a intervenant et avec
étudiants et c'est ouvert aussi pour le
public c'est ouvert grand public qui
voudrait bien vous voir c'est ouvert
dans des conditions dans des disons faut
rester dans des dans des proportions
acceptestion acceptbl mais tant que
l'ENFI peut tenir la population c'est
possible bien évidemment et pour plus
d'information un site internetation sur
facebook disons on nous retrouve Agora
VSQ et puis donc ça sera le 14 décembre
à partir de 15h30 très bien merci
beaucoup d'être venu témoigner de votre
engagement dans le bénévolat engagement
associatif sur ce plateau merci
donc à syv cardinal l'associatif se
porte bien dans le département des
ivelines le bénévola avec 150000
bénévoles vous n l'avez dit et puis 12
million en France la France championne
d'Europe dans ce domaine merci donc à
tous les deux on va passer à présent à
la chronique culture la culture c'est
avec Joan s dans un instant